an old factory Holland Germany serves as
a garage for vintage classics mostly
British with flashing chrome
pascale cop owns them all he lives for
his classic sports cars the designs and
mechanics are important to him and
everything in combination the form is
what tells him this isn't XK the coupe a
or the C type there's something about
the design that can't be reproduced and
modern car makers can't get close to
there are nice ideas in modern cars but
he says lots and lots of great things
were around back then that you just
don't see anymore
great things like the mg c GT severing
most of the fewer than five thousand
sufferings were made in 1968 hardly any
originals have survived their popularity
as racing in rally cars landed many in
the junkyard
pascal runs an event agency
he loves tooling around country roads in
a separate
Pascal says the sound the look and the
handling are all things modern cars
lacked
hearing the Weber carburetor moan as it
sucks in air when you open it up give
some much more of a thrill than any kind
of modern fuel injection could the mg in
the name is the car maker while the C
stands for the six-cylinder engine and
GT designates the closed roadster body
style the Seberang named after the
racetrack in Florida was the racing
version with broader fenders and a 200
horsepower engine
Pasco cop explains that at the time mg
Motorsports relatively small engine
Department built the severing for the
submarine races but as far as he knows
none of the original cars have survived
to the present day
they had aluminum engine blocks of which
none are left
of course he says they were fitted with
Weber carburetors and the cars had
adjustable chassis so they were more
than well-equipped when it came to the
engine the maximum speed of some 220
km/h was impressive for 1968
under the hood was what he calls a
whopper of an engine a three liter
single cast six-cylinder block the
standard version delivered 145
horsepower and the modified version some
200 horsepower
pascale have his mg remate built by a
specialist in england six years ago and
he's been improving it here and there
ever since he's given it a dependability
unaccustomed with British cars
pascale cops car was perfectly equipped
for rally racing including a trip master
odometer and a passenger side reading
land
and the bucket seats and racing
seatbelts provide perfect support Cusco
regularly takes part in classic car
rallies and for several years now he's
even organized his own
he's been competing with his own rally
team since 1997 but if it weren't for
the extremely positive response from the
teams as well as the spectators he
probably would have quit long ago they
only do it for the fun of it every time
it's a special experience Pascal is
always on the lookout for unusual routes
for his rallies his current project is a
10 Lake rally through the foothills of
the Bavarian Alps she takes care of a
painting the permits planning the routes
and coming up with ideas for his special
stages
a route has to fulfill various
suitability criteria the countryside
should be picturesque not have too much
traffic and not be too hard on the aging
collectors items house cow points out
that it's also important to have plenty
of food and drink on hand so people
don't have to wait in line the
competitions are varied not all the
participants are after the grand trophy
for the best time most of them come to
have as much fun as they can get I'm
dusty lights but we push past sometimes
but in the end only a well-fed classy
car rally driver is a happy one
so Pascal gives high priority to good
food and good quick service it should be
filling but not exhausting he works with
the ins managers to put together the
menu and the schedule
nothing is really at stake here but
everyone has at least some ambition
since 1997 the motto for his rallies has
been fun leisure and culture and that's
exactly what he wants it to be the top
priority is for everyone to have fun and
Pascal Cup has fun especially when he's
out and about and one of his darlings
hunting for fun and beautiful roots for
his next rally